Senator Al Gore author of the book earth
in the balance ecology and the human
spirit what's it all about it's about a
global ecological crisis that is in my
opinion the most serious problem our
world faces it covers a lot of seemingly
separate problems that are all part of
the same underlying crisis you know the
old parable about the blind men and the
elephant one had a hold of a leg the
other the trunk the other the tail and
it took them some time to realize that
all of these separate parts were parts
of the same large entity when I first
got involved in studying about problems
relating to the environment I had some
similar difficulties I saw the problem
of ozone depletion and climate change
toxic waste disposal the rainforest
destruction all as seemingly separate
problems I've now come to the conclusion
that they are all symptoms of a deeper
underlying crisis which is a collision
between our civilization as it's
currently constituted and the ecological
system of the earth the relationship
between human beings and the earth as
described in Earth in the balance has
been changed profoundly in our lifetimes
the population explosion new scientific
and technological inventions that
magnify the power we have to exploit the
earth and a relatively new way of
thinking that we are separate from the
earth isolated individuals entitled to
exploit it as much as we want and that
way of thinking is what really needs to
be changed first graphic inside the book
and we're gonna it's a close-up of this
right here we're gonna pull back and as
you pull back you begin to see something
else yeah that is part of an experiment
that was done to determine what is the
minimum amount of information needed by
the human mind
to decipher an image this of course is
Abraham Lincoln but when you see it
close up it just looks like a jumble of
light and dark squares when you when you
pull back from it as we were a moment
ago the pattern is much easier to see
and our way of looking at the evidence
concerning the global environmental
crisis presents us with a similar
challenge if we just look at regional
problems or local problems they look
like a jumble of meaningless data but
only by gaining the perspective which
distance grants us in time and and space
can we see that the earth is a unified
whole and that it is now facing this
unprecedented ecological crisis which
can be solved and I wrote earth in the
balance not only to describe the causes
and the roots of the problem but also
the solutions for it but the first
challenge is to see it to recognize it
there's an old story about a science
experiment involving a frog that's
dropped in a pot of boiling water and it
jumps right out and then the same frog
is put in a pot of lukewarm water which
is slowly brought to a boil and the Frog
just sits there until it's rescued the
Frog used to be boiled in the story but
I've learned how important it is to
rescue the Frog but the point of that
story is similar to the point of that
graphic the frogs nervous system is so
primitive it needs a sudden jolt a
sudden contrast to make the connection
between the changed circumstances and
the danger it faces and what it needs to
do to save itself and we're like that
frog in that when we see and hear these
signals from around the world the
disappearance of the RLC the Love Canal
the garbage barge the ozone hole there's
a very long list the process of change
they represent seems deceptively gradual
in the context of a human lifetime but
in
of history it's actually very sudden and
the question is when are we going to
jump when are we going to put two and
two together and recognize that we have
a responsibility to the future to do
something about it you right and the
introduction that a baseball game and
your son has something to do with
getting you interested enough to write
this book I went through a change in my
life when my son was almost killed a
couple of years ago it was a shattering
experience for my family he has had a
miraculous recovery and we're very
blessed and very grateful to all the
doctors and nurses who helped to make it
possible but during the long weeks when
my wife and I were in the hospital room
with him I began to really look at life
a little bit differently and ask
questions about what's most important in
life and having already long since been
deeply involved in this issue I began to
look at it differently also instead of
seeing it just as an outgrowth of the
new scientific and technological assault
on the earth and the population
explosion which is adding one China's
worth of people every ten years now I
began to to feel that the deeper causes
are within our own lives as individuals
what gives us the notion that we are
just isolated one from another with no
responsibility to the future our
children are going to live no connection
to the communities in which we live out
our lives and I began to explore in a
very personal way what it is that leads
to these false assumptions and how we
can get on with the task of of solving
this crisis and organizing a response
that gives our children and
grandchildren and generations to come on
earth that is not diminished and
degraded by virtue of what we're doing
in our short lifetimes how is your son
oh he's doing great he's had a full
recovery
he's doing terrifically well I might say
that during that episode I learned
something else to those who had suffered
the most in their own lives seemed to
have the most to offer to my family and
me by way of comfort and understanding
and the sharing the prayers the reaching
out from so many people we never even
met was a healing experience and a
profoundly moving experience in a sense
it gave me permission to fully
experience my own grief to allow myself
to feel what the enormity of what had
happened and what we were going through
and I don't know I'm I'm in my early 40s
and maybe it's a time when people
naturally begin to question the the arc
of their lives certainly that's the
that's the case with me and that that
experience brought a lot of things home
in a way that caused me to ask different
and I think better questions how many
kids do you have
only four children and our son is our
youngest we have a freshman in college
and a 14 year old and the 13 year old
three girls and a boy how close did he
come to dying well to close it was when
I reached him he had no breath no pulse
and two nurses who were off-duty working
at Johns Hopkins happened by and thank
God they were able to baseball we were
at the opening day season opening day
came in in 1989 and how long did he
spend the hospital and in convalescence
because you say that you spent a lot of
time thinking about this stuff we were
in the hospital 30 days and then there
were follow-up procedures for a long
time and he needed micro surgery on his
nerves in several months after that he
lost the use of his
right arm for quite a while totally
restored now and then the physical
therapy which continued you know I did
not realize how many and this is my own
failing but it's something that you
learn when you go through through an
experience like that I did not realize
how many people I was working with on a
daily basis who had gone through the
same thing maybe not exactly the same
injury or tragedy but emotionally they
had gone through the same thing so many
families experiences and people that you
meet in everyday life they'll be walking
down the street or in the office where
you work are sometimes curing some very
heavy burdens and not talking about them
but they're really having that weight on
their hearts even as they're going about
their daily tasks without saying
anything about it
and I my eyes were really open to a lot
of things like that did you write the
book yourself every single word of it
and people in my profession sometimes
are suspect in that category but as you
know I was a journalist for seven years
before I got into politics and I'm quite
familiar with word processing and
writing and although I must say the
difference between writing a daily story
or some daily stories and writing a book
was a difference that I did not fully
appreciate until I got up to my elbows
in this and it's a different breed of
cat what is the main difference there's
a difference in the temporal reality
stamina is is one of the most important
qualities you have to bring to the task
if you've got a long newspaper story
even a weekly story and you get behind a
little bit you can pull an all-nighter
and
get it finished or you can just really
buckle down and set aside four to six to
eight hours and get it done with a book
particularly one like this that's of
course entirely out of the question this
was a three year effort the first two
years were focused mainly on the
research and organizing the tasks
talking with people getting all the
ducks in a row and then immediately
after the excuse me immediately after
the re-election campaign of 1990 in
November of 1990 after my own Senate
re-election I just cleared the decks and
wrote in a very concentrated way day and
night weekends for a full year after
having gotten all the research lined up
on the cover has this picture been seen
before that particular image has not
been seen to my knowledge anywhere but
on the cover it's an actual photograph
of the earth put together by a man named
Tom Van Sant he selected from thousands
of satellite pictures of the earth the
images that gave a cloud free view of
every square inch and the the large flat
version of that has been seen and in
fact has been used by National
Geographic as the frontispiece of their
new atlas of the earth and in other
places but he put the images together in
a in a globe onto a globe and this one
for example is the only image I know of
that shows a clear view of the North
Pole the Arctic ice cap in summer one
interesting feature of the picture of
Bryon is that the northern and southern
hemispheres are both in summer at the
same time because the pictures were
taken over a three-year period and he
selected summer exposures if you look
close you can't see it with your cameras
but you can actually see down in South
America you can see the freshwater of
the Amazon River coming coming out into
the
South Atlantic there it really is a
extraordinary picture one of the things
that I noticed as I read it come across
the page and I'd say when I got back
from the North Pole or when I got back
from the rainforest or one how many
different places have you been in the
world in order to write the book Lots
I've I've engaged in a concentrated
effort to go to the front lines of this
ecological crisis over the last several
years the North Pole the South Pole the
Amazon the air all see places where
environmental tragedies are most visible
where the impact of our civilization on
the Earth's ecology is easiest to see
people that you've met along the way
that you'll remember well a lot of them
there are people who I describe as
resistance fighters individuals who are
standing in the path of the bulldozers
people who like Chico Mendes have been
assassinated for the work that they have
done oh who is he who was it he he was a
man in the Amazon region of Brazil who
spoke out against the widespread burning
and and cutting of the Amazon rainforest
and organized those who live in the
rainforest and around it to use the
rainforest in a sustainable way to
harvest the renewable bounty of the
rainforest but wealthy landowners who
want who wanted to just burn it down and
clear it for a year's worth of cattle
ranching hired an assassin to kill him
more than a thousand others were killed
just in the last year not as well known
as Chico Mendes but this is a in in some
ways like a war these resistance
fighters have no hope of winning unless
their courage arouses the conscience of
the rest of the world and that is
beginning
to happen I report on some of those in
various countries who are becoming quite
successful at getting the message out we
have this misconception sometimes that
it's the developed world against the
developing world but just as some of the
worst ecological catastrophes are in the
developing world some of the most
eloquent spokesman and spokeswoman for
what can be changed are there to a woman
like Wong gari mitai in Kenya who has
planted with her organization more than
seven million trees in the last few
years to help stop soil erosion which is
at epidemic catastrophic levels
throughout much of the third world where
she planning on eroded hillsides in
villages and they choose a indigenous
species native species that are
genetically prone to do well in the
climate and the region where they're
planning where she get the money to
afford seven million trees well it's the
this the seeds are not expensive and her
women's groups that's how it started in
each village plant there's little
nurseries themselves and then they they
compensate the people who plant the
trees not for planting the trees but for
ensuring that the trees survive only
after they have reached a stage of
growth that makes makes it very likely
that they that they will stay there do
they get to the little compensation
involved but she raises the money
herself Cristina and Woodrow Stirling of
Thun Tennessee who are they they are two
people who contacted me when I was in
the House of Representatives many years
ago about a funny taste in their well
water and they had done a little
detective work on their own and had
discovered that a chemical company from
70 miles away in Memphis had been
trucking its chemical waste to the rural
area where the
Berlin's live and dumping it into
shallow trenches in a way that caused
contamination of the water table and
after looking into it I then shared the
first hearing on chemical waste disposal
and we had the sterlings come and
testify and folks from a little
community in upstate New York known as
Love Canal which later became of course
a nationwide and even worldwide symbol
for the problem of toxic waste disposal
you have a lot of other names here
Maryland Bullock Maryland Bullock is a
very energetic woman a mother from
Henderson County Tennessee who woke up
one Christmas Eve morning to the news
the startling news that her County had
just been selected as the site for a
chemical waste disposal of landfill and
a company had come in and secretly
through intermediaries bought up the
rights to 2,000 acres and you talk about
ruining somebody's Christmas that
community that entire community rose up
in arms and they said this is not going
gonna be allowed to happen here by the
time I got there a few weeks later the
County Courthouse on the inside was
completely plastered with individual
posters from schoolchildren every
schoolchild in the county had done a
poster about why the environment of that
county had to be saved and how much they
were opposed to letting this chemical
waste be dumped there and they didn't I
mean the attitude was really
extraordinary they just said very
confidently this is not going to be put
here and they went about learning the
facts related to chemical waste disposal
and they very carefully said we don't
want to just save our own backyards we
don't want the kind of thing there
posing here to be done anywhere in the
country I I responded to them by having
a congressional hearing in a nearby city
and some national experts on the problem
came and said they're right and they had
done their homework and the whole
project had to be scrapped
what's changing now is it is something
very similar to what changed in that
county when they woke up on Christmas
Eve morning ah all across this country
there are groups who are concerned about
where a landfill or an incinerator is
going to go because they feel their
backyards are threatened what's changing
now is the definition of backyard and
when enough people make the connection
emotionally not just intellectually
between the devastation of the global
environment and their own backyards
we're going to then feel the same
intensity brought to the global
environmental questions that are now
brought to these local environmental
disputes one example in your backyard
Bryant
here in this studio the air that we're
breathing while we're talking has 600
percent more chlorine atoms in each
breath we take right now than it did
when you and I were born and that's true
at the North Pole and the South Pole and
everywhere on earth in just 40 years
time we have multiplied by six the
number of chlorine atoms in every part
of the Earth's atmosphere
now that doesn't hurt our health
directly but it does burn a hole in the
ozone layer and let's in more
ultraviolet B radiation which suppresses
the immune system and causes more
cataracts and more cases of skin cancer
and an extra two hundred thousand deaths
from skin cancer here in the United
States alone in the next few decades now
that's in my backyard in your backyard
but in order to protect our backyards we
have to address our
to the changes taking place in the
global environment and kids are now
beginning to make that connection
we've got to start making that
connection to Linda Draper
Linda Draper is a really neat person
whose family worked for years for the
General Electric Company and she bought
a GE refrigerator and it worked fine and
one day a serviceman knocked on her door
and said we've got to tell you that
there's a problem with the refrigerator
you bought but don't worry
we're gonna replace the defective part
before you have any problems and in a
manner of speaking the company was
trying to go out of its way to to do the
right thing it thought but when the
repairman started to change the
compressor and put in the new one he
said would you mind opening your kitchen
window and she said sure why and there
was a loud whoosh those were the CFCs
the chlorofluorocarbons rushing out into
the Earth's atmosphere well Linda had
been doing volunteer work for an
environmental group she's very concerned
about the global environment and she
figured out what was happening and she
just went nuts I mean that's the wrong
way to put it she she got very concerned
and she said what are you doing and then
she'd dug into the facts and found out
that the company was doing this with
millions of these things and accounting
for lots of chlorofluorocarbons going
into the atmosphere and she just said
stop and she called the company they
didn't respond she went to an
environmental group they did respond in
general yeah that's right and then she
went to an environmental group they came
to me with Linda and explained the
problem and they were prepared to have a
nationwide boycott and I of GE products
and I said wait a minute let me talk to
the company and I did and and we we had
a good conversation and I said can't
isn't there some other way to make this
a win-win
situation instead of a lose-lose outcome
and to their credit they bucked it up to
the CEO level and they really put their
thinking caps on and they came up with a
very innovative solution and as a result
there was no net increase in CFCs in the
environment and they developed a new
unit to scavenge chlorofluorocarbons
anytime a similar situation is faced by
them or any other appliance manufacturer
in the future and they're now trying to
lead the way on this particular question
so it turned out to have a happy ending
and it serves as an example of a change
that's happening with a lot of
businesses northern telecom if I can
mention another one it happens to be
headquartered in Nashville Tennessee
when the problem with
chlorofluorocarbons was first addressed
by the Montreal Protocol that's the
worldwide treaty that was signed in 1987
a lot of companies said you know we
can't ban chlorofluorocarbons nothing we
can do about it northern telecom said
let's get rid of them whatever it takes
and they went to work and just a few
weeks ago they had a worldwide
celebration
they'd beat the deadline by nine years
and got completely rid of them and they
found out in the process that the new
process they developed is cheaper and
the products have a higher quality as a
result and that's not unusual when
companies pay attention to what to the
details of how they can eliminate
wasteful pollution they end up
eliminating wasted money too and they
drive creativity and come up with new
discoveries so there's a there are a lot
of hopeful stories in earth in the
balance because some of the problems are
so tough they sometimes seem impossible
to solve but it's important to recognize
that people are beginning to solve them
we can solve them we must and we will
you say in the introduction you say I
use CFCs in my automobile air
conditioner for example on the way to a
speech
why they should be banned as I said
earlier I've done a lot of introspection
and soul-searching and into the way I
myself react to this problem and I'm a
little more sensitive now a lot more
sensitive now to some of the things I do
that are habits that are hard to break I
still drive my car more than I feel is
right I sometimes run to work now and I
feel better for having done it but but I
still use a car more than I should and
but I don't think that people should
feel so guilty about things like that
that they're just paralyzed from doing
anything about it
I concede a certain level of hypocrisy
in that I am working on this practically
all the time and yet the patterns that I
still have in my own life still help to
contribute to the problem but I'm
changing my family is changing and I
want to see that public policy changes
along with the commitment of individuals
who are getting involved in this I've
talked to some people who have gotten
into recycling in a big way and have
then become frustrated when the stuff
they collect piles up and they can't
sell it because the community in which
they live hasn't gotten on the ball and
put a good recycling program into place
you really do have to have both the
personal commitment first to learn about
it and then to change the patterns in
our lives and then also you have to have
the public policy framework that
encourages and facilitates the kinds of
changes that millions of people are
anxious and ready to make can you give
any other example of something in your
life you've changed or something around
the Senate that's changed because of the
concern sure on the Rules Committee I've
taken the lead in pushing forward a
Senate wide recycling program the
architect of the Capitol was already on
the case and
didn't take too much of a nudge but the
Rules Committee was very actively
involved on both sides of the aisle in
pushing this forward and now we're gonna
have a very effective recycling program
in the Senate we specifically around the
Senate offices absolutely everywhere in
glass or glass cans and we recycle in my
home I can't take credit for my family
getting into that because my children
led the way on that and that seems to be
a common pattern among the families that
I talk with sort of like seat belts your
kids bug you to wear them and a lot of
families that are wearing them for that
reason recycling is the same way and I
might say this to Brian what I found in
researching the book and in working on
this problem is that kids are generally
more active and more involved with this
issue than older parent and then their
parents or older Americans are I ask
them routinely in elementary schools do
you think you're more concerned than
your parents and they always say a
hundred percent of them raise their
hands and say yes when I ask them why
they say because we're gonna be around
longer than they are sometimes a teacher
will leap out of the side of the
classroom and say we didn't have the
facts we didn't know everything that
these kids are being exposed to but one
of the reasons I wrote earth and the
balance is to put in one place all the
facts for anybody who is curious about
why their kids are so involved in this
issue and what families can do to
address the issue you write I have
become very impatient with my own
tendency to put a finger to the
political winds and proceed cautiously
yeah that's more of that introspection
that I talked about earlier I think that
one of the problems with our political
system in both parties is such a
sensitivity to the short-term
fluctuations in public opinion
that a lot of elected officials are too
timid and and less willing to to to go
out in front of public opinion and say
look I've taken the time to investigate
this problem and you may not yet agree
with what I have to say but I'm asking
you to take the time to check what I'm
telling you and then see if you don't
agree that's called leadership and I
don't think we have enough leadership in
either political party now certainly not
from from President Bush on this
particular question but let me just talk
about my own experience when I ran for
president in 1988 you know I used to be
the next president of the United States
and when I started that campaign I said
the number one issue in my campaign is
going to be the global environmental
crisis and the next day some of the
pundits said how naive he is this is not
going to be an issue and I guess to an
extent they were right but I don't think
they're right for long and even if they
were right looking back on that campaign
now I wish that I had been more willing
to say in every single speech right up
front in the speech this is the main
issue and I'm going to hammer away at it
even if the news media doesn't cover it
or doesn't put it on the a list of
issues let me use an analogy the savings
and loan crisis wasn't mentioned in that
campaign either but if one of us who ran
had taken the time to dig into the facts
of that before the election and had
brought out the the facts about the
crisis to the people we might have saved
the taxpayers hundreds of billions of
dollars and had an impact on that
election campaign in 88 in the process
jumping to a chapter called self
stewardship
they read a half a paragraph 30-second
television commercials and sophisticated
public opinion polling can now calibrate
and target a political message with
frightening speed and accuracy and they
can do more to manipulate the opinion
pinions of voters in two weeks in all
the speeches and debates and political
organizations together can accomplish in
ten years you really mean that and if
you do why do you go through all the
process of Senate debate and speeches on
the road and all that if all you need is
30-second television commercials to get
a message across
well one of the reasons why the Senate
floor is practically deserted during
most speeches is that most of my
colleagues know that what will matter at
election time is the 30-second
commercials and what will not matter
very much usually is the long speeches
that are made on the substance of the
issues that we're dealing with I don't
mean this as an advertisement for c-span
but thank goodness that we do have a
c-span because otherwise nobody would
ever hear those speeches at all it's one
of the the only remaining links between
the American people and the kind of
government that our founders expected
that we would have just as technology is
a big part of the problem where the
global environment is concerned
technology is part of the problem where
our political process is concerned as we
become more familiar with the technology
of television and short commercials I
think some more creative ideas will
emerge for using the technology to
reclaim the meaningful dialogue that
must take place between politicians and
people between elected officials and
people for example I've recommended that
the key debates on matters of greatest
import on the Senate floor ought to be
scheduled consciously at a
I'm when people are able to watch on
television I'd like to see c-span in
primetime competing with all of the
other things that that are on television
with the with the best most passionate
most heated most meaningful debates that
the Senate has scheduled consciously for
those primetime hours then when enough
people started tuning in at that time
you'd get more senators and congressmen
coming to the floor jumping up to
participate when a debate went in in a
way that they didn't like and and we
would have a better chance to
reinvigorate political debate in this
country but but there's one ingredient
that has nothing to do with technology
nothing to do with commercials and that
is a willingness of the individuals in
the political system to to speak what's
on their hearts and and to be willing to
take a long-range view and and and
really look beyond the next election or
the next State of the Union speech or
tomorrow's daily public opinion poll
wait are you up for election again I'm
not up for another four years and have
you as long as we're talking about
elections have you ruled out running for
president again I announced last August
that I wouldn't run in 1992 and I said
at the time that in my opinion President
Bush was going to take a nosedive in the
public opinion polls and I said if I
made the decision for political reasons
I would run but part of the healing
process my family has been going through
that we talked about a little bit
earlier has made me change the way I try
to discharge my commitment to my family
during this period when my family is a
little more vulnerable than than normal
our whole family was hit hard by the
accident that we talked about and it was
just inconsistent with that healing
process for me to rip myself out of
their lives and go out on the campaign
trail full-time for two years or a year
and a half or a year or whatever and put
my whole heart and soul into a
presidential campaign it was not the
right thing for me to do personally this
time around I hope that I'll have
another chance at some point in the
future I know that his time waits on no
person and I know that I may never have
another chance like this one even if
that's true I'll never have second
thoughts about this decision this year
but if I do have another chance I will
run for president up the subject but if
you didn't run for president and you
weren't a United States Senator what
other professions have you found that
you'd be interested in what other things
would you want to do in your life I'd be
a writer I'd be a full-time writer so
this was an interesting experience for
oh sure was well I was a full-time
writer for seven years just before I got
into politics and I I was in it long
enough to get the the printers ink in my
veins a little bit and I really do like
the process of writing I'm one of those
people who finds it easier to understand
something in the process of trying to
communicate it and express it not
everybody's like that but there are a
lot of us I know that for a fact but I'm
like that and so I do like to to to
search my own thoughts in the process of
trying to communicate them to others
Houghton Mifflin is a publisher what got
them interested Houghton Mifflin is a
terrific publishing company I've been so
impressed with him they're very
conscious of their tradition of
publishing books on the environment they
were the publishers of Silent Spring by
Rachel Carson back in 1962 in fact going
farther back than that they were the
publishers of on Walden Pond by Thoreau
and they just have a very strong
commitment to the overarching issue
and the editor-in-chief John sterling
took a personal interest in the project
he became my editor I had worked with
him you know it's a normal relationship
but just every single day and since he
is in New York and I'm mostly here we
really burned up the the telephone lines
going over every every page and I
learned a lot from the editing process
because the editors I've worked with in
the newspaper business taught me a lot
but as we were saying earlier a book is
so different rearranging the flow of
ideas and concepts with an eye to the
arc of the whole book is something that
that is akin to an art and I gained a
tremendous amount of respect for what
good editing it is all about and John
sterling really did a super job is it
well known that people read a book in a
certain way in other words did they read
the first couple chapters and sometimes
skip over the middle and then end up in
the I mean I for instance when I read a
book for this program I often read the
back before I read the front because I
want to get all the little details on
how this thing came together I think I
think most people write books as if
they're gonna be read from front to back
continuously I'm not sure everybody
reads them that way you don't but the
arc of a book is constructed according
to that assumption a book starts in a
particular place and then takes the
reader through the full text and then
ends in in the right way and if your
experience is as mine was in writing 30
word leads and relatively short
newspaper stories it's you have to make
a transition to to capture that sense of
how long the arc of a book is my editor
was very helpful in in in helping me
gain that understanding I wrote it in
sections not chapters I mentioned that I
took
years before I actually started the
writing process to organize research I
pasted things up on the wall and and
every area was a different part of the
book I ended up with 45 sections and
then they were aggregated in into
chapters and actually there was a
surgery from time to time to rearrange
the weight chapters were put together
and that again was a was a new
experience for me
no I should point out that Silent Spring
came out in 1962 Rachel Carson was the
author I didn't know that it was
Houghton Mifflin but your mother read
the book and had an impact on you sure
did it was a big topic of dinner
conversation in our family and my sister
and I were impressed by the intensity my
mother brought to that subject it was
clearly different than other subjects
that had made an impression on her and
what was different about it is that
something you couldn't readily see or
taste or smell or hear was being spread
throughout the environment and having an
impact that could only be perceived in
the cycle of the seasons with the
disappearance of songbirds in in that
case and the songbirds are disappearing
and incidentally one of the facts in the
book is that if you measure the
pesticide use in Rachel Carson's time
and compare it to now the world is using
13,000 times as much pesticide as it was
when Rachel Carson wrote Silent Spring
up front you have a dedication in the
book here to your sister I assume
because of the dates that you lost your
sister back in 1984 how she died of lung
cancer and she was the very first
volunteer for the Peace Corps first-ever
first-ever
worked with bill moyers and Sarge
Shriver and Harris Wofford the group
that put the Peace Corps together and
she was a great person and I I feel
emotional just just remembering how much
she meant to me she when I first ran for
public office she told her husband she
was going to have to take a few months
away from from him and came and took the
toughest counties that I had in that
district and and just worked full-time
and really made the difference
I didn't write about this in the book
Brian but when when she died I had a lot
of thoughts about lung cancer and
smoking there are a hundred thousand
tobacco farms in Tennessee but most
tobacco farmers would prefer that their
own children not not smoke and our
country's been wrestling with that issue
I think there is a parallel to this
issue there are some scientists who are
employed by tobacco companies who still
argue that there's no link between
smoking and lung cancer I don't think
any of them has ever held a hand of
somebody who died of lung cancer and
breathed their last breath if they did
they they wouldn't continue to make such
a facile and wrong argument but you know
if you look at this at the details of
the science they really don't know
exactly how smoking causes lung cancer
but the weight of the evidence is clear
350 thousand people a year die as a
direct consequence of smoking cigarettes
now I said that it is an analogy our
global civilization is now at the
equivalent of a 10 pack a day habit you
know all those oil wells that were on
fire in Kuwait with a smoke blackening
the sky all of them put together on the
worst day put less than 1% of
the pollution into the Earth's
atmosphere that we put into the Earth's
atmosphere every day and there's some
people who say no problem it's not going
to cause any harm they're wrong
dire straits the rock group has a line
in one of its songs denial ain't just a
river in Egypt it's a psychological
strategy like putting your head in the
sand and some people who are addicted to
alcohol for example will see a string of
drunk driving accidents as unrelated
misfortunes when actually they're
connected well we look around the world
now and we see these ecological
catastrophes that are beginning to
resemble what the comedian a Whitney
Brown called a nature hike through the
Book of Revelations and yet a lot of
people see them as just sort of
unconnected misfortunes and wonder
what's going on they're connected
they're connected to a pattern of
addiction our civilization is in a very
real sense addicted to a pattern of
consuming the earth's resources in a
completely unsustainable way and just as
with other addictions there is an aspect
of distraction involved there's a
certain frenzy in this attitude you've
seen the the old the funny poster he who
dies with the most toys wins shopping is
now a recreational activity of you know
there's a and people who are constantly
doing this are often not happy at all
people question whether their lives have
have a deeper meaning this is at bottom
in my opinion a spiritual crisis the the
assumption that we are separate from the
earth separate from each other separate
from the communities in which we live
and that the only thing that matters is
just get it while we can right now and
don't worry about the future that
produces a very profound uneasiness in
people and the in
our mental crisis is the single most
serious manifestation of this deeper
crisis near the end in the chapter
called conclusion you you write some
things I want to this will take a couple
seconds I want to write read this to the
audience and the resurgence of
fundamentalism in every world religion
from Islam to Judaism to Hinduism to
Christianity the proliferation of new
spiritual movements ideologies and cults
of all shapes and descriptions the
popularity of new-age doctrines in the
current fascination with explanatory
myths and stories from cultures the
world over all serve as evidence for the
conclusion that there is indeed a
spiritual crisis and modern civilization
that seems to be based on emptiness at
its center and the absence of a larger
spiritual purpose what are you getting
in I think we are connected to each
other I think we do have a larger
meaning and purpose in our lives I talk
about my own religious faith in in this
book and my faith teaches that we are
given dominion over the earth but we're
required to be good stewards of the
earth and it my faith teaches that the
purpose of life is to glorify the
creator of life other faiths state the
same principle in different ways but the
underlying assumption is that we are
part of something larger than ourselves
and that our lives have meaning within a
larger context if we cut ourselves off
from that larger context whether it is
defined in spiritual terms or whether it
is defined in the terms of an agnostic
might use a connection with future
generations perhaps we we are part of
something that extends beyond the
boundaries of our skin beyond the the
term of our own lives
we are here because of what came before
us and what happens after us will depend
in large measure on decisions and
choices that we make in our lifetimes
it's an illusion
for us to suffer the conceit that we
have no responsibility to those who come
after us if I can just make one other
reference to my own personal religious
faith there's a parable in two of the
Gospels that make up my faith about the
it's called the parable of the
unfaithful servant it's a very simple
story the master of a house leaves on a
journey and tells his servant while I'm
gone
if vandals come and ransack this house
or thieves come and steal my belongings
if you tell me you were asleep that will
not be a good enough excuse I believe
that this is God's earth I believe that
we belong here but we have a
responsibility to take care of it and
right now there is environmental
vandalism on a global scale and many
seem prepared to say well we were asleep
we didn't know what was going on we
didn't realize that that we were causing
such damage and allowing such damage to
to occur I think we have a
responsibility to something larger than
ourselves to stop this environmental
vandalism do you realize that the
leading scientist in in the world now
say that if the current rate of species
loss continues more than half of all the
living creatures God put on this earth
will disappear within the lifetimes of
our children extinction is a natural
process but now it's proceeding 1,000
times faster than it has ever happened
in the
sixty-five million years because of what
our civilization is doing and we've got
to speak out and stop that and we know
how to stop it the solutions are in
earth in the balance and can be
implemented as soon as a political
consensus is formed as it's already
forming among young people as it's
already beginning to form in Europe and
Japan and elsewhere and as it will form
here when more time passes and when we
have new leadership at what point in the
process will you review the success of
this book or the process of this book
and determine that it was all worth it
and what will what will have to happen
to make it all work well I've already
reached that point if I never sold a
single book or never got it into the
hands of a single reader it would have
been worth it for me because it enabled
me to search my own heart my own
feelings and thoughts about this crisis
and this challenge in a way that I would
not have done otherwise I'm of course
very gratified with the extremely
favorable reviews that are have been
coming in and the response when people
walk up to me at bookstores and say I've
already read it I'd like you to sign it
but it really moved me and that's of
course icing on the cake and I'm very
gratified by that but but the real
payoff if you will would be if it
contributed in some small way to
speeding up the formation of that
political consensus that I talked about
earlier which convinces the political
system to move see I think that change
in our political system is like change
in the global environment it doesn't
always occur slowly it bills toward a
threshold and then the system adopts a
new pattern I think that when enough
people become convinced that this has to
be a priority then the political system
will start falling all over
itself to come up with creative
responses we just have a moment and
people have to buy the book if they want
to learn your proposal on global
Marshall Plan but it's a rather
extensive plan for the future at what
point do you think you really have a
shot at getting a global Marshall Plan
paid for by this country well it
shouldn't be paid for by this country
our part of Japan Europe the oil-rich
countries this has to be a global effort
the first step internationally it is to
make the effort to save the Earth's
environment the central organizing
principle for the post-cold war world
just as we bent every effort to defeat
communism now on a global basis we have
to develop this shared commitment to
bend every effort towards saving the
Earth's environment that sounds and
seems impossible to many right now just
as a few years ago it seemed impossible
to expect the Soviet Union to disappear
in all of Eastern Europe to be free and
democratic in capitalist but when enough
people change their way of thinking
about communism then what seemed
impossible became imperative now as more
and more people are changing their way
of thinking about the Earth's
environment and our responsibility to it
what seems impossible will become
imperative this is what the book looks
like it's called earth in the balance
ecology and the human spirit by Senator
Al Gore a Democrat of Tennessee thank
you for joining us thanks for doing such
a thorough job Brian appreciate it